[Musique]
Johannesbourg Afrique du Sud
les équipes au sol se préparent pour
l'arrivée d'un hélicoptère
l'attention est élevée et la sécurité
renforcée c'est l'un des nombreux hélico
qui atterrissent ici chaque jour
la cargaison ainsi que sa provenance
sont un secret bien gardé
à bord ni leader international ni PDG
d'un grand groupe mais une seule
marchandise de l'or sa valeur plus d'un
million de dollars
[Musique]
cet or provient du bassin de 8
waterground la région des terrains
orifères d'Afrique du Sud les plus
riches du monde
[Musique]
et les plus profonds
ça ressemble à une répétition pour la
descente aux enfers on sent qu'on est
bien loin de la réalité du Voyage au
centre de la terre de Jules Verne
ces mines d'or plongent à 5 km sous
terre
c'est là qu'une force de travail
équivalent à celle d'une petite ville
creuse 24 heures sur 24 des hommes qui
triment pour extraire un métal ayant
toujours joué un rôle crucial à travers
les civilisations
aucune autre richesse en effet n'a
autant présidé à la destinée de
l'humanité
[Musique]
siècle avant Jésus-Christ ce sont déjà
des pièces d'or qui tissent les liens
essentiels du commerce
des empires sont érigés et chutes à
cause de l'or
les routes commerciales qui relient les
marchés d'est en ouest sont pavés d'or
de l'Amérique du Sud à l'Afrique du Sud
on s'est battus pour l'or
[Musique]
pour l'amour de l'or on conquiert le
Nouveau Monde et les civilisations
telles que les Aztèques et les Incas
vont être anéantis
on commence par utiliser ce métal
étincelant pour en faire des parures il
devient ensuite objet de culte
[Musique]
des Israélites fondant leur bijoux pour
en faire le veau d'or aux Indiens
d'Amérique du Sud qui surnomme l'or la
sueur du soleil les cultures ont
traversé les siècles avec la conviction
que l'or possède des propriétés divines
[Musique]
la Bible elle-même parle des Rois Mages
venus célébrer le roi nouveau-né en lui
faisant donc d'or
de tout temps et en tout lieu de
l'Égypte au Pérou l'homme a orné ses
palais et ses temples de ce métal
intemporel
[Musique]
on estime que depuis l'Antiquité on a
extrait entre 130 et 140 millions de
tonnes d'or
si on fondait cette quantité d'or en un
seul et unique bloc on obtiendrait un
cube d'environ 20 mètres de côté soit un
cinquième du Washington Monument
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle on est aussi
précis dans ces chiffres provient de la
nature même de ce bien l'or est une
matière indestructible les objets en or
découverts dans les tombes égyptiennes
ont effectivement gardé la même
apparence depuis qu'ils ont été créés
lors demeure intacte qu'on l'enterre
pour 2000 ans ou bien qu'on le laisse
immerger 2000 ans quand on retrouve une
pièce d'or elle fait exactement le poids
qu'elle faisait à l'époque il est fort
probable que l'or était était le tout
premier métal travaillé par l'homme
il est extrêmement malléable on peut
étirer une simple once d'or à peine 30
grammes en un fil de 80 km de long ou
bien l'aplatir en une feuille de 100
mètres carrés
l'or est si inaltérable qu'on l'appelle
le roi des métaux il résiste au ravage
du vent de la pluie et du temps
je ne crois pas qu'il existe un
quelconque autre élément qui est ses
qualités exceptionnelles il ne ternit
pas il brille pour toujours et ne se
dégrade pas l'argent s'en rapproche le
platine aussi mais il n'y a rien de
comparable à l'or
on trouve de l'or sur tous les
continents mesdames nature se le garde
jalousement
le métal précieux est maintenu en
prisonné dans les filons de quartz au
cœur de la roche des six montagneuses
au tréfond de la terre
soumise au travail infini des vents et
des pluies la roche alentours finit par
s’éroder et lors par affleurer
les anciens se servent en paillettes et
en pépites qu'ils trouvent dans les
cours d'eau ou les morceaux de roche
mais lorsque les rois commencent à
régner il ne manquent pas d'instaurer
leurs règles d'or le métal précieux
devient leur monopole quelle que soit
l'endroit où on le découvre
[Musique]
donner son premier coup de pioche pour
de l'or revient alors à mettre le doigt
dans un commerce impitoyable
[Musique]
lorsque les Égyptiens conquièrent la
Nubie ils a servi ce son peuple aux
mines d'or
lorsque les Romains conquièrent ce qui
est aujourd'hui l'Espagne ils
asservissent le peuple au mine d'or et
quand les Espagnols conquièrent le Pérou
eux aussi à service le peuple au mine
d'or du pays le métal obtenu est le plus
magnifique qui soit mais bien souvent
les gens qui l'extrait travaillent dans
des conditions les plus inhumaines et
les plus misérables qu'on puisse
imaginer aussi je pense que puisque la
recherche de l'or a toujours été plus ou
moins incessante elle s'est souvent fait
d'une manière impitoyable
mais alors va bientôt se voir soustrait
à la mamie terrible des rois
tout commence à basculer un matin de
printemps 1617 lorsque trois navires
jettent l'encre sur les côtes de
Virginie
jamston est le premier village
britannique digne de ce nom dans le
Nouveau Monde à s'établir dans l'espoir
de trouver de l'or les commanditaires du
voyage ont ordonné à ses fondateurs de
ne pas rentrer au pays sans rapporter de
ce métal jaune dont ils ont entendu dire
qu'on le trouvait en abondance aux
Amériques
parmi les premiers colons figurent deux
orfèvres et deux affineurs de métaux
mais la fièvre de l'or est contagieuse
le capitaine Smith écrit dans son
journal de bord
la pire entourloupe c'était nos
affineurs tout clinquant qu'ils étaient
avec leurs promesses dorées il n'y avait
pour eux pas d'autres mots d'autres
espoirs ni d'autres travaillent que de
creuser pour de l'or laver l'or affiner
l'or seulement voilà il n'y a pas d'or
les colons de jamstowns vont s'aventurer
jusqu'à 60 km à l'intérieur de terre
sauvage dans une course insensée de
crédule qui croit bientôt toucher aux
miracle ce n'est que près de 200 ans
plus tard que l'on va commencer à mettre
à jour des quantités importantes d'or
dans le nouveau pays indépendant
un dimanche matin de 1799 Conrad read
alors âgé de 12 ans sèche la messe pour
aller pêcher
ce qu'il trouve ce jour-là dépasse de
loin tout ce qui sera donné de trouver à
John Smith et à d'innombrables autres
pionniers américains
de l'or non seulement le bien le plus
précieux de l'époque mais surtout une
seule et unique pépite de 7 kg
sa famille n'a pas la moindre idée de ce
qu'elle tient entre les mains
pendant des années elle utilise cette
pierre comme butoir de porte
jusqu'à ce qu'un bijoutier du coin en
entendre parler il achète le trésor pour
3 dollars et demi la pépite en vaut
alors presque 5000
au début du 19e siècle des milliers
d'Américains sont à pied d'oeuvre pour
trouver de l'or sur les contreforts
montagneux de la Caroline
pendant 30 ans cet or qu'ils extraits
aident les États-Unis à alimenter sa
monnaie
mais rapidement ce flux d'or se
transforme en un filet
reste alors à découvrir les grands
gisements
[Musique]
une découverte effectuée à l'ouest de
l'Amérique voilà naissance d'une
nouvelle profession le chercheur d'or
c'est le début d'une ruée vers l'or qui
va transformer l'ouest du pays
le symbole chimique a eu pour l'élément
or provient du latin au rhum qui
signifie aube luisante
en 1848 une découverte accidentelle en
Californie va offrir au tout un chacun
pour la première fois de l'histoire une
chance de s'enrichir grâce à l'or
tout commence en 1839 avec John Sutter
un homme ambitieux émigré du village de
Kandern en Allemagne
cette heure se pose en Californie
décidait à fonder un empire agricole sur
les collines fertiles qui entoure la
vallée de Sacramento
c'est là qu'il érige un fort afin de
protéger ses biens en plein essor à
peine 10 ans plus tard il totalise 1200
têtes de bétail et plus de 100 employés
et il a ce projet qui est de développer
une minoterie afin de pouvoir subvenir
aux besoins alimentaires des gens qui
viennent s'établir à l'ouest
pour ce faire 7h a besoin de bois de
charpente lorsque les paddes dénommé
James Marshall a touche à tout itinérant
le Maine au fort de cette heure ce
dernier l'embauche et lui confie la
construction d'une Syrie
les ouvriers ont dû creuser un immense
fossé pour amener l'eau jusqu'à la Syrie
et l'extrémité la plus basse du fossé
qu'on appelle le bief arrivé au niveau
du soubassement du terrain
c'est là que le matin du 24 janvier 1848
James Marshall qui effectuait son
contrôle de routine a observer une fente
au sol dans laquelle il a remarqué un
morceau d'or
Marshall hésite à deux reprises avant de
prendre la peine de se baisser pour le
ramasser
je me suis assis et j'ai commencé à
réfléchir très sérieusement j'avais le
cœur qui battait fort j'étais certain
que c'était de l'or
le morceau faisait à peu près la moitié
de la taille et avait la forme d'un
petit pois
[Musique]
Marshall parcourt ce jour-là 65 km pour
le montrer à 7h lequel écrira plus tard
Monsieur Marchal a commencé par me
montrer ce métal en fait des petits
fragments et spécimens dont certains
pouvaient valoir quelques dollars il m'a
annoncé qu'il en avait parlé aux
ouvriers à la Syrie comme quoi c'était
peut-être de l'or 7h décide de garder
secrète la découverte jusqu'à ce que
l'un de ses ouvriers s'arrête en Ville
prendra un verre sans argent sur lui à
la place l'homme fouille sa poche et en
sort une pépite jaune trouvé dans un
ruisseau il la pose bruyamment sur le
comptoir voilà de l'argent c'est de l'or
déclare-t-il la transaction a lieu dans
une épicerie générale tenue par un
mormon du nom de Sam branan lequel ces
deux ou trois choses sur la situation de
l'offre et de la demande à la frontière
Sam branan n'a pas fait ce que tous les
autres ont fait c'est-à-dire se
précipiter à la Syrie pour commencer à
creuser au lieu de ça il est descendu à
San Francisco et a acheté tout ce que
ses bras aient rapporter en matériel
dans les mineurs auraient besoin dans
les mois suivants puis branan fait en
sorte de s'assurer que les mineurs
arriveront en full
il a arpenté les rues de San Francisco
en criant haut et fort la nouvelle de la
découverte de l'or dans la rivière
américaine de l'or de l'or dans la
rivière américaine
lorsque la nouvelle parvient dans l'état
d'Orégon deux tiers des hommes bons pour
le service font leur baluchon et partent
pour la Californie il s'autoproclame
chercheurs d'or trouver le métal devient
leur nouveau métier un fonctionnaire
espagnol à montéré observe
les fermiers ont laissé de côté leur
charrues les avocats leur dossiers les
médecins leur pilulent les prêtres leur
misselles et tous se sont maintenant mis
à creuser pour de l'or
les nouvelles se transmettant encore
plus vite par voie maritime les chinois
sont informés avant les New-Yorkais
les nouvelles ont mis tellement de temps
à parvenir à l'est du pays qu'on a
surnommé ses gars ceux de 49 en
l'occurrence 1849 au lieu de ceux de 48
en 1852 la population de la Californie a
plus que décuplé pour arriver à 250 000
personnes
c'est pratiquement le monde entier qui a
participé à la ruée vers l'or on peut
lire sur les registres que des gens sont
arrivés du sous-continent indien de tous
les pays d'Europe aussi d'Australie
d'Amérique du Sud et bien entendu en
particulier des États-Unis
trois itinéraires possibles vers les
terrains orifères sauf aux quelques
80000 américains qui quittent la côte
Est
par train le voyage prend jusqu'à 6 mois
par bateau en contournant l'Amérique du
Sud il peut aussi durer 6 mois
ou bien encore par voie maritime et
terrestres en empruntant l'ishme de
Panama le chemin le plus court mais
aussi le plus coûteux
ces trois solutions engendrées de toute
façon énormément de souffrance il y
avait la fin et la maladie terrible les
nombreux dangers aussi il ne faut pas
oublier non plus le mal du pays et la
peur l'inquiétude aussi à la fois pour
la famille qu'on laissait et pour ce
qu'on allait trouver pour survivre en
Californie
lorsque les bateaux accostent à San
Francisco les marins allaient chez par
la perspective de gagner 20 ans de
salaire en seulement deux mois de
prospection se joint une top passager et
les accompagne dans cette rue et vers
les régions aurifères
le SS californien arrive en avril 1849
avec un équipage de 36 hommes en
quelques jours il n'y a plus à bord que
le capitaine et un mécanicien
un autre capitaine de navire va même
jusqu'à pendre aux extrémités d'une
vergue deux déserteurs en guise
d'avertissement mais en vain la fièvre
de l'or fait délire le monde
c'était la chance de toute une vie pour
beaucoup de gens qui ne connaissaient
que la pauvreté tout à coup on leur
annonçait cette nouvelle extraordinaire
avant la découverte à la Syrie De Sutter
lors que l'on trouvait devenait
immédiatement propriétés des rois et des
conquérants la rue est vers l'or en
Californie introduit une nouvelle donne
ou tout simplement la chance pour le
commun des mortels de pouvoir chercher
et garder pour son compte tout ce qu'il
trouvera
vous avez là tout à coup des mineurs
indépendants qui se débrouillent seuls
dans le froid et la pluie qui extrait et
fouille le gravier aurifère à s’ambriser
les reins
c'est tout à fait unique dans l'histoire
du monde
les gars de 49 dénichent une région
rocheuse riche en or qu'on surnommera le
filon mère
au fil de millions d'années l'or est
emporté par les torrents et parvient
jusqu'à la rivière c'est pour ça qu'on
parle de sable ou de gravier aurifères
mais si la Californie est inondée d'or
l'argent lui-même se fait rare le point
d'approvisionnement en valeur le plus
proche est Philadelphie située de
l'autre côté du pays les Californiens
vont donc improviser en utilisant la
monnaie étrangère présente sur place
le dollar espagnol en argent appelé la
pièce de 8 était ce qu'on trouvait le
plus communément il leur fallait le
découper en 8 petits morceaux chacun
ayant une valeur de 12,5 cents pour 6
morceaux par exemple on avait le droit à
une coupe de cheveux et un rasage mais
David brodric nouvelle arrivant de New
York comment s'acheter de la poussière
d'or en la fondant en pièce il permet
aux californiens de se constituer une
réserve d'argent devenu désormais
indispensable
on s'est aperçu plus tard que ces pièces
soi-disant de 5 et de 10 dollars or
n'était peut-être pas faite uniquement
d'or Broderick c'est donc constitué un
bon pactole avec son affaire
broderie qui n'est pas le seul
entrepreneur à faire fortune sans avoir
jamais touché la roche à l'apogée de la
ruée samranan qui ravitaille alors les
mineurs devient l'homme le plus riche du
pays
est connu comme le tout premier
millionnaire un million de dollars en
poudre d'or sans avoir donné un seul
coup de pelle
cependant seul une poignée des gars de
49 sortira riche de l'aventure
en 1849 la Californie a produit 10
millions de dollars en or
misé par une moyenne de 40 000 mineurs
cela fait approximativement 250 dollars
par tête
mais les gens continuent d'affluer par
centaines et par milliers attirés par
les histoires extravagantes qu'on
raconte sur cette ruée
en 1851 la production atteint 77 tonnes
la majeure partie part pour l'Est du
pays une cargaison annuelle dont la
valeur dépasse le budget fédéral tout
entier
en 1853 on atteint les 93 tonnes
mais leur facile qu'on pouvait laver à
la bater dans les ruisseaux et les
rivières et d'ores et déjà pratiquement
épuisée l'heure du déclin a sonné pour
la ruée vers l'or californien l'aventure
n'aura duré que quatre courtes années
mais elle reste fondamentale pour le
développement à venir de l'Ouest
américain
d'une portée bien supérieure à tout
autre aventure de ce genre dans
l'histoire pas seulement pour la
quantité d'or extrait mais pour ce que
la concrètement apporté aux États-Unis
ces mineurs à court d'or qui se sont
aperçus que ça ne valait pas le coup
décide alors de revenir à ce qu'il
maîtrise le mieux il crée donc des
fermes en Californie qui s'avèrent plus
productrices
comme pour le reste de l'histoire de
l'Ouest américain le développement a un
coût l'immigration massive bouscule un
système économique et social en place
depuis des siècles
les différentes ruées vers l'or ont eu
des effets dévastateurs sur les
populations indiennes ça a été le début
de la fin de leur mode de vie
en l'espace de 5 ans la population
indienne en Californie passe de plus de
150 000 habitants à moins de 30 000 la
plupart des victimes meurent de faim ou
de maladies les autres sont assassinés
par les mineurs
les initiateurs de la ruée suivent un
chemin analogue James Marshall l'homme
qui avait trouvé la première pépite dans
la rivière passe le reste de sa vie
ivrogne et fauchée à chercher en vain à
notre gisement
[Musique]
quant à l'Empire agricole prospère de
John setter il est anéanti ses ouvriers
se sont rués vers les champs orifères
abandonnant les terres au squatteurs
évoque dans ses Mémoires son rêve brisé
cette découverte soudaine d'or a détruit
tous mes beaux projets si j'avais réussi
seulement quelques années avant qu'on ne
trouve de l'or j'aurais été le citoyen
le plus riche de toute la côte pacifique
mais au lieu d'être riche je suis ruiné
certains gars de 49 ne parviennent
pourtant pas à se débarrasser de leur
fièvre de l'or dans le demi-siècle qui
suit d'autres ruées ont lieu de par le
monde
chacune d'elles déclenche une véritable
migration de chercheurs muée par la
seule rumeur de la prochaine grande
découverte
dans la fièvre de l'or un gars de 49
ruiné découvre de l'or sous terre la
veine principale d'or qui a alimenté la
grande rue et californienne le filon
mère comme on l'appelait est en réalité
une veine de quartz se comportant de
l'or et qui s'étend sur plus de 160 km à
travers les montagnes du nord de la
Californie
en 1850 Edouard argrive alors âgé de 34
ans rentre chez lui en Australie après
avoir passé deux ans à chercher de l'or
en Californie bien qu'alors sans le sou
argrive s'aperçoit que la géologie dans
la région californienne qui l'a connu et
semblable à celle de la nouvelle galle
du Sud en Australie il prédit à l'un de
ses camarades de voyage qu'il trouvera
de l'or en l'espace d'une semaine
il y a autant d'heures dans le pays où
je rentre qu'en Californie et sa
Gracieuse Majesté la Reine Dieu la
bénisse menera parmi ces hauts
commissaires de l'or
art graves n'est pas loin de la vérité
en 1851 à peine 6 semaines après son
retour il découvre en compagnie d'un
guide dont il a loué les services de
l'or dans sa bataille
en six mois quelques 50000 chercheurs la
plupart d'anciens protagonistes du rêve
californien s'en tiche de l'Australie
[Musique]
quelques mois plus tard les nouvelles de
la découverte parviennent en Angleterre
accompagnée de la toute première
cargaison d'or australien le capitaine
du bateau à vapeur Thomas harburnotte
écrit
notre colonie est complètement paralysée
tout homme ou garçon capable de tenir
une pelle et déjà partie ou bien par
creuser à peu près tous les produits
alimentaires ont augmenté parfois
jusqu'à 200% de leur prix
l'Australie autrefois colonie
pénitentiaire redouté par les détenus
britanniques devient subitement la terre
promise pour quiconque possède un rêve
et une pelle
en 1852 372 milles immigrants ils sont
installés
c'était simplement des gens ordinaires
qui se disaient c'est l'armée vers l'or
on se lève on y va et on essaie de
s'enrichir mais comme pour la Californie
la ruée australienne sera de courte
durée en 4 ans tout l'or ni chiant
surface est dans les cours d'eau est
accaparé les fanfaronnades d'Edouard
sont devenus réalité
la reine Victoria le nom au commissaire
au terre outre une bourse de 10 000
livres sterling elle lui attribue un
mandat à vie bien qu'il ne découvrira
plus jamais d'or par la suite argrive se
continuera d'être vénéré comme l'homme
ayant le don de transformer en or tout
ce qu'il touche les ruées vers l'or
californienne et australienne font du
commun des mortels des chercheurs à
temps partiel je suppose que c'était
presque devenu une semi-profession dans
la seconde moitié du XIXe siècle vous
étiez chercheur d'or l'oreille
constamment à l'affût des derniers
potins et des derniers mots d'ordre qui
couraient dans les bars avec la
Californie et l'Australie dorénavant
hors-jeu l'ultime odeur devient dans les
Rocheuses Abily a leur âgé de 40 ans
n'attend pas qu'on le lui dise deux fois
en 1859 il quitte sa ferme de l'Arkansas
après avoir entendu une rumeur circulant
parmi des mineurs travaillant le long de
la rivière et selon laquelle il y aurait
de l'or dans le Colorado au printemps
1860 lits trouve enfin ce qu'il cherche
dans leur ravin d'une montagne c'était
plein d'or et il y avait plein de
couleurs qui roulaient dans sa battait
et il a fait le rapprochement à ce
moment-là j'ai toute la Californie dans
cette bataille c'est le nom qui a fini
par coller au ravin le ravin californien
c'est reparti comme en 49 la première
année le ravin californien produit plus
de 2 millions de dollars en or
cette première ruée était exclusivement
une ruée vers les sables orifères il
suffisait de trouver le métal selon une
méthode qu'on qualifierait aujourd'hui
de méthodes géochimiques ça consistait à
détecter de petites quantités d'or par
l'action de la gravité en remuant
doucement la bataille
la découverte fait à Lille rameute des
chercheurs d'or du monde entier
énormément de gens s'étaient déplacés
depuis les pays de l'Est au printemps
1860 10000 personnes sont arrivées pour
tenter de s'installer directement dans
le rabat californien
il a donc fallu répartir rapidement les
8 km du ravin en petite concession
individuelle la plupart ne dépassant pas
30 mètres de long
il y avait des slovennes qui occupaient
l'ouest de la ville les Hispaniques
étaient à string Town les Suédois sur
chicken Hill et les Irlandais dans la
sixième rue litteville ou ville du plomb
est une petite agglomération d'appels 2
km² perché à quelques 3300 mètres dans
les montagnes Rocheuses du Colorado à la
suite de la découverte d'Abily les
milliers de mineurs qui affluent vers ce
camp reculer s'aperçoivent bientôt que
les pages sont également riches en autre
type de gisement au cours des 30 années
qui suivent on creuse plus d'un millier
de plus de mines où sont extraits de
l'or de l'argent du zinc ainsi que le
métal qui donnera en 1878 son nom à la
ville le plomb
une communauté rudimentaire et
désordonnée je me souviens avoir lu un
article publié en 1893 qui disait que
lidwil était la communauté minière la
plus célèbre que le monde est jamais
connu
les Devil était réputée pour ses salles
de jeux et ses maisons closes
la proportion était de 10 à 20 bars ou
maison de passe pour une école ou une
église
l'un de ces mineurs partit à la
poursuite de leurs rêves dans les rues
de Itteville n'est autre que Thomas Wolf
un immigrant irlandais arrivé en 1879
pour chercher de l'or pendant 15 ans
Wolf pioche et tient le reste du temps
un bar à Itteville il a auparavant
travaillé dans l'une des nombreuses
affineries de métaux qui font vivre
l'industrie minière de la région
en 1895 l'ironie du sort veut que Thomas
Wolf tombe littéralement sur une mine
d'or
c'est une chance tout à fait
exceptionnelle qui ne doit vous arriver
qu'une fois dans la vie parce que
l'endroit au-dessus duquel il s'était
établi cette masse riche en minerais
orifères avait été fouillée 15 ans
auparavant par des mineurs persuadés
qu'il allait y trouver du minerai
d'argent des gens qui avaient commis
l'erreur de ne pas essayer comme on dit
pour les minerais celui se trouvant à
portée de leur pioche lorsque lui-même
après levé des échantillons qu'il a
essayé se minerai s'est avéré être très
concentré en or
en 1879 on découvre de l'argent à Lille
des centaines de mines poussent comme
des champignons pratiquement du jour au
lendemain cependant les années 1880
voient l'argent se dévaluer
progressivement au fur et à mesure que
les pays du monde entier passent à un
nouveau standard l'étalon or la mort
annonçait de ce métal autrefois précieux
se termine en faillite totale beaucoup
des concessions sur l'argent sont
automatiquement abandonnés
aussi dans les mois qui suivent Wolf se
rachète discrètement 50 concessions à
leur désertées qui s'éparpillent sur les
hauteurs entourant les villes il
effectue des travaux de consolidation et
s'inspire d'une petite montagne rocheuse
surnommée le jet pour baptiser son
domaine la mine aux oiseaux l'endroit va
devenir la plus grande mine d'or du
monde et faire de Wolf un
multimillionnaire
il fait cependant figure d'exception si
quelques-uns font fortune à une ville la
plupart ne trouvent rien ou alors très
peu d'or
la vie dans ses communautés minières
étaient très très difficiles tout le
monde s'imaginait que la pellete
suivante il allait toucher le filon mère
mais malheureusement ça n'arrivait que
très rarement
la plupart rentrait chez eux à bord de
chariots connaissent Toga typique de
l'époque très souvent il peignait une
petite Maxime en guise de blason sur la
toile du chariot tape dans le mille ou
rien et quand il revenait chez eux à
l'est il disait souvent qu'ils avaient
été plumé par Dieu
alors que le XIXe siècle touche à sa fin
les chances de faire fortune dans l'or
s'amenuise
la toute dernière occasion pour les
chercheurs se présentent en Alaska
lorsqu'on découvre de l'or dans la
rivière clondik en 1896 des milliers
d'entre eux déboulent
le billet du voyage en paquebot qui
jusque là coûtait 50 dollars passe à
1000 dollars
mais le bateau n'effectue qu'une partie
du périple
[Musique]
les chercheurs doivent encore parcourir
un long chemin semé d'embûches sur une
des terres les plus hostiles qui soient
[Musique]
la police montée canadienne s'affaire
d'ailleurs à empêcher de se lancer dans
l'aventure qui compte que n'importe quoi
avec lui au moins une année de réserve
de nourriture
un major de la police montée écrit on a
du mal à imaginer une telle scène de
ravage et de désolation des milliers de
chevaux étendus morts janché le chemin
parfois par grap entière sous des
appliques il gisait à côté de leur
harnais de leur sel de leur fardeau
tomber avec eux du haut des rochers mais
les chercheurs poursuivent leur parcours
sans se laisser abattre puisque tant
d'or avait été découvert dans tant
d'endroits différents il reste convaincu
qu'il faudra peu de temps avant qu'on ne
mette à jour le prochain film
et donc les gens avaient l'habitude de
se demander où aller avoir lieu la
prochaine ruée la Californie est arrivée
assez vite à saturation mais il y avait
eu tant d'autres histoires dans les
années 1850 et 60 on a lancé tout à coup
de l'or à Seattle ou ailleurs absolument
partout et les gens se précipitaient
alors que bien souvent il n'y avait rien
dans ces endroits là
ce sont de solides gaillards qui ont
fait les grandes rues et vers l'or du
19e siècle des individus solitaires au
rêve immenses par paillettes grains et
quelquefois par pépites entières ils ont
lavé à la battée lors qui a transformé
l'histoire
à chaque annonce de la découverte d'or
de la Californie à l'Australie en
passant par l'Alaska le monde entier
s'est précipités pour filtrer les
rivières mais les cours d'eau ne sont
pas la seule cachette de l'or on
s'aperçoit bientôt que le métal jaune se
dissimule également dans les collines
environnantes malheureusement il faut
bien plus qu'une simple pelle et une
battait pour l'atteindre
l'exploitation minière de l'or rencontre
bientôt la révolution industrielle
c'est la ruée vers l'or australienne qui
permet de mettre à jour la plus grosse
pépite jamais trouvée un bloc de 70 kg
d'or
à la fin de l'hiver et au début du
printemps 1876 alors que le général
George hey Custer se prépare pour son
tristement célèbre rendez-vous avec
Little Bigorne les frères Fred et Moses
manuels à chercher de l'or dans les
collines noires au sud du Dakota né au
Québec les frères manuels ont passé
l'essentiel de leur vie à arpenter
l'ouest des États-Unis en quête
improbable d'or comme beaucoup avant eux
ils ont entendu des rumeurs voulant que
les géologues du général Custer et
trouver de l'or dans les collines noires
le 9 avril 1876 les deux frères
découvrent ce qu'il cherchait dans une
zone connue sous le nom de ravin du
Bobtail Moses relate leur découverte
dans son journal finalement la neige
s'est mise à fondre sur la colline l'eau
s'est écoulée par le filtre qui traverse
le tuyau là j'ai vu du quartz j'ai
attrapé une pioche pour essayer d'en
casser un bloc mais il était très
compact je suis tout de même arrivé et
je l'ai ramené au camp pour le concasser
le laver ensuite à la battée
en quelques mois Fred et Moses manuels
ont extrait pour 5000 dollars d'or une
vraie petite fortune pour l'époque un an
plus tard les deux frères vendent leur
mine pour 45 000 dollars le gisement
devient l'une des premières propriétés
de la home state mining company la
création de la mine de homstake annonce
une révolution dans l'exploitation
minière de l'or au cours des siècles
suivants le chercheur d'or solitaire
équipé de sa battée et de sa belle va
progressivement céder sa place à de
grosses sociétés utilisant de nouvelles
technologies l'une des méthodes les plus
efficaces mais aussi les plus
destructrices pour l'environnement
consiste en l'exploitation minière
hydraulique
il s'agit de faire passer de l'eau dans
une énorme lance et de la projeter avec
force contre la roche pour un désagréger
les morceaux principaux en balayant
littéralement le quartz on laisse ainsi
apparaître l'or
les canons à eau anéantissent des
millions de mètres cubes de terre et de
pierre à flanc de coteaux sous
dépression qui pourraient mutiler ou
tuer un homme à 30 mètres
en moins d'une journée on fait table
rase du lit de rivière qu'un bataillon
de chercheurs bardé de pelles et de
battés Aurélien moi a passé au tamis
d'anciens sites miniers datant des
premières ruées reprennent alors vie
une autre bénédiction tombe en 1889 pour
les compagnies minières il s'agit du
cyanure anassis de mortel pour l'homme
mais qui s'avère être d'un grand secours
pour l'industrie
on s'est aperçu que le cyanure avait la
faculté de dissoudre la roche autour de
l'or c'est devenu très économique pour
une industrie qui utilisait des
techniques à grande échelle et pouvait
ainsi espérer récupérer jusqu'au dépôt
de très faible quantité d'or
ces avancées en matière de technologie
minière font de la mine de homstake la
plus riche de l'histoire des États-Unis
pendant plus d'un siècle elle continue
de produire de l'or en quantité
régulière il représente 10% en tout de
la totalité de l'or exploité dans les
mines d'Amérique
Fred et Moses manuel avaient découvert
l'une des énormes réserves d'or
dispersés dans tout l'Ouest américain
plusieurs années plus tard en 1962 des
géologues localisent dans les montagnes
du Nevada un champ aurifère de plus de
1600 mètres de profondeur par 1600
mètres de long mais l'or lui-même reste
invisible à l’œil nu
[Musique]
de nos jours la compagnie minière Berric
utilise des techniques innovantes afin
de récupérer de microscopiques grains
d'or de l'ordre de quelques millièmes de
millimètres pour les voir il faudrait
les grossir pratiquement 2000 fois
après la découverte des gisements de la
région de Karline ainsi que la mise en
œuvre des technologies modernes les
États-Unis sont devenus le second
producteur d'or au monde
la découverte des plus grandes réserves
d'or qui soit est située dans l'un des
environnements géologiques les plus
rentables et les plus exceptionnelles de
la terre
les voleurs savent que l'or et
dorénavant capable de révéler leurs
empreintes digitales grâce à un nouveau
type d'analyse chimique capable
notamment d’indiquer précisément le lieu
de provenance du métal
nous sommes dans la mine du Grand oligo
dans la région du Transvaal en Afrique
du Sud
c'est puis serpente jusqu'à 5 km sous la
surface de la terre
chaque mois la mine traite une moyenne
de 209000 tonnes de roches et de résidus
en un an elle produit plus de 28 tonnes
d'or
le grand oligo n'est que l'un des très
nombreux sites miniers exploitant les
riches terres d'Afrique du Sud
la signification de cette région pour
l'industrie de l'or est simple elle a
produit à ce jour près de 40% de tout
leur extrait à travers l'histoire
un jour de 1886 infirmier du nom de
George Harrison travaille à déterrer des
pierres afin de construire une maison
dans la banlieue de johannesbur
lorsqu'il tombe sur un véritable filon
Harrison autrefois chercheur d'or
pendant la ruée en Australie comprend ce
qu'il a heurté avec sa pelle
ce n'est pas une pépite d'or massif mais
du minerai de fer contenant de l'or il
vient en fait de trouver un minuscule
gisement de surface qui n'est autre que
la partie affleurante d'une immense
réserve d'or souterraines laquelle
s'étend sur des centaines de kilomètres
à travers la campagne sud-africaine il
n'existe au monde aucune autre formation
de ce type
l'Afrique du Sud est un cas tout à fait
extraordinaire dans le sens où l'on est
en présence d'un gisement dont les
géologues prétendent qu'il provient d'un
très vaste lac souterrain alimenté par
des rivières
ce serait donc que cette géologie unique
qui a généré la plus grande région
productrice d'or au monde
comme pour toutes les autres découvertes
de gisements la nouvelle de celle de
Harrison se répand comme une traînée de
poudre
[Musique]
le problème c'est que la majeure partie
de cet or est enfouie loin sous la
surface
on a affaire qui s'enfonce très très
profondément dans le sol il descendent
jusqu'à 3 km et demi vous comprenez que
ce n'est plus du domaine du petit
chercheur d'or
ne s'enfonce pas seulement loin il est
également difficile à traiter il faut
écraser 5 tonnes de roches pour un
extraire moins de 30 g d'or comme pour
les autres grandes découvertes d'or à
travers le monde à la fin du 19e siècle
les rêves de George Harrison comme
d'autres chercheurs d'or vont être
récupérés
l'époque où il s'agissait de saisir la
prochaine grande découverte et révolue
l'extraction de l'or en Afrique du Sud
en Australie et aux États-Unis
s'effectue dorénavant sous le contrôle
de grandes firmes
tout à coup apparaissent des compagnies
minières dotés d'un gros capital qui
investissent massivement dans le
développement des mines d'or
elles sont suivies par une très large
main d'oeuvre prête à travailler au fond
de ses mines pas toujours dans les
meilleures conditions
en 1900 l'Afrique du Sud produit un
quart des réserves annuelles mondiales
en or plus on trouve dehors plus les
pluies s'enfoncent profondément
certaines de ces mines descendent
pratiquement jusqu'à 5 km avec des
galeries qui serpentent encore sur
d'autres kilomètres et dans toutes les
directions les mineurs qui travaillent
pénètrent dans un autre monde tout
commence par une descente à pique en
ascenseur qui dure un quart d'heure
vous enlevez tous vos vêtements et vous
revêtez une tenue spéciale avec un
casque ensuite vous rejoignez cet
immense cage il y a énormément de bruit
et de grandement tout autour de vous
c'est comme si vous descendiez
littéralement au centre de la Terre
et plus vous avancez plus il fait chaud
sans la présence d'un des plus gros
climatiseurs jamais imaginé la
température dans ces mines atteindrait
les 60 degrés centigrade nous sommes ici
dans les mines les plus profondes de la
terre celle où le travail est aussi le
plus intense
en Afrique du Sud les filons d'or
s'étendent sur des centaines de
kilomètres et personne ne sait jusqu'à
quelle profondeur il s'enfonce on sait
juste qu'ils sont très minces
c'est un peu comme si l'on observait la
viande à l'intérieur d'un sandwich on a
cette ligne très étroite qui sont les
écailles d'or emprisonnés dans la roche
c'est à ça qu'on doit s'attaquer on
s'échine à dégager et à sortir de là
cette tranche à 3 km et demi sous terre
une fois extrait du sol l'or est affiné
sous forme de barbe brutes c'est-à-dire
contenant 80 à 90% d'or pur de la taille
d'un petit pain une barre brute pèse
tout de même jusqu'à 32 kg une
plaisanterie dans les mines d'Afrique du
Sud consiste à dire que si vous parvenez
à soulever l'une de ces bars il vous
suffit alors de l'emporter et là vous
vous dites ah oui d'accord
ensuite on place ces barres dans un
hélicoptère pour les convoyer jusqu'ici
pour des raisons à la fois de sécurité
de vitesse la cargaison est déposée le
matin avant 11 heures
[Musique]
cette barbe brute aura été transformée
en or fin
48 heures plus tard elle sera
probablement déjà dans le coffre d'une
banque quelque part dans le monde
laffine rede est la plus grande
affinerie au monde
[Musique]
c'est ici qu'on transforme l'or en
lingot en pièce en plaquage et en fil
près d'un tiers de l'or extrait dans
toute l'histoire de l'humanité affranchi
les portes de la finerie ronde
il y a de fortes chances pour que lors
de votre monde de votre bague ou encore
à l'intérieur de votre bouche reviennent
directement de ce haut lieu chaque jour
en Afrique du Sud des hélicoptères font
la navette non-stop entre la mine et la
fine riz puisant dans l'inépuisable man
on est bien loin du chercheur d'or
solitaire de sa modeste battée et de ses
beaux rêves
[Musique]
l'or ou l'un des biens les plus
convoités de l'histoire
métal jaune et fascinant pour qui des
empires ont été bâtis et des
civilisations détruites
depuis qu'on a commencé à l'extraire au
cœur de la terre il a suscité des
guerres et des hommes ont tué où sont
morts pour lui
au premier siècle avant Jésus-Christ le
poète romain Virgile nous met en garde
contre l'obsession de l'or qui l'appelle
la soif maudite
en découvrant le Nouveau Monde 1500 ans
plus tard un explorateur italien va sans
le savoir lancer le processus de la ruée
vers l'or
impitoyable et dictatorial celle-ci
mènera à la disparition de toute une
civilisation le 3 août 1492 Christophe
Colomb is les voiles pour le plus grand
voyage de découverte de toute l'histoire
il cherche une route occidentale qui le
conduisent jusqu'en Asie contemplant son
destin que l'on se met à prier
notre Dieu en les mains de qui tout
repose venait à mon secours portez moi
là où je pourrais trouver l'or deux mois
plus tard le 12 octobre il tombe par
hasard sur une île inhabitée dont il
revendique la propriété pour la reine
Isabelle et le roi Ferdinand d'Espagne
sans savoir qu'il vient de toucher la
terre des futurs américains colon pense
avoir débarqué dans ce qu'on appelait
les Indes la partie orientale de l'Asie
l'une des premières choses qu'il
remarque alors qu'il tombe sur les
indigènes qu'il appelle logiquement des
Indiens et que ceux-ci porte sur eux de
l'or
samedi 13 octobre 1492 ils ont apporté
des écheveaux de fil de coton des
perroquets des flèches et d'autres
choses qu'il serait fastidieux des
Numériques je restais attentif et me
donner du mal à vérifier qu'il possédait
bien de l'or je remarquai que certains
d'entre eux en avaient un petit morceau
attaché à un trou sur le nez
Ferdinand Isabelle d'Espagne voulait de
l'or il savait que c'est ce dont ils
avaient besoin pour financer pour
maintenir ainsi que pour étendre leur
pouvoir
la revendication des Indes par colon
place l'Espagne son voisin le Portugal à
deux doigts d'entrer en guerre quelques
40 ans plus tôt le Vatican a en effet
accordé au Portugais un droit exclusif
sur les Indes même si les explorateurs
portugais n'y ont encore jamais mis des
pieds on est donc en présence de
revendications contradictoires et comme
les deux pays sont de confession
catholique il se rendent auprès du pape
afin d'éviter un conflit
l'Espagne a un avantage de taille le
pape nouvellement élu est Alexandre VI
en espagnol
dévoué à Isabelle et à Ferdinand
il a été décrété qu'on devait tracer une
ligne qui séparerait le monde entre une
partie revenant aux Espagnols et l'autre
au Portugal
et c'est à cause de cette ordonnance que
toute l'Amérique latine parle espagnol à
l'exception d'une large partie nord-est
qui est aujourd'hui le Brésil où l'on
parle le portugais
si ce partage du globe par le pape
permet d'éviter une guerre il fournit
bientôt à l'Europe une excuse pour sa
conquête des Amériques
l'une des premières colonies dans le
Nouveau Monde se situe sur l'île
d'hispanola les Espagnols que colon il
laisse vont effectivement y trouver de
l'or et par la même occasion à servir
les autochtones afin de l'extraire on
rapporte cet or à Isabelle et à
Ferdinand
on trouve une partie de cet or ici dans
l'église Santa Maria Maggiore à Rome
c'est en quelque sorte un cadeau de
remerciement du couple royal espagnol au
pape Alexandre
à la fin du 15e siècle début 16e on a
refait le plafond on l'a décoré avec de
l'or dont la tradition veut qu'il fasse
partie du tout premier or en provenance
du Nouveau Monde des Américains
et lorsque vous regardez bien ce plafond
vous vous apercevez qu'à certains
endroits on dirait véritablement de leur
massif
[Musique]
colon meurt en 15 sens 6 convaincu
d'avoir touché terre en Asie
en lui consacre une tombe au style
sophistiquée à Séville en Espagne
au moment où l'explorateur décède des
milliers d'Indiens meurent également à
Hispanola
mais en bien moins grande pompe les
conditions de vie très rude ainsi que
les maladies introduites par les
Espagnols ont fait énormément de
victimes en 1519 la population
d'indigènes a chuté de 100 000 personnes
à moins de 3000
ceci ne stocke pas pour autant le flux
continu d'or vers l'Espagne
je dirais que le meilleur exemple qu'on
ait gardé de cette quête acharnée de
l'or et l'ordre que le roi Ferdinand II
d'Espagne est censé avoir donné à ses
amiraux en partance pour l'Amérique du
Sud prenez l'or avec humanité si vous le
pouvez mais prenez-le à tout prix prenez
l'or et je pense que malheureusement ils
ont pris ça au mot
Francisco Pizzaro un aventurier
analphabète figure parmi les plus
barbares
Pizzaro appartient à une nouvelle race
d'explorateurs espagnols qu'on appelle
des conquistadors il a déjà suivi
pendant 10 ans d'autres conquistadors en
Amérique centrale en 1523 à l'âge de 48
ans il se sent prêt à diriger des
expéditions
franchement je ne suis pas allé là-bas
convertir ces gens tout le monde veut
s'en occuper je suis allé là-bas
chercher de l'or
pendant 9 ans Pizzaro c'est Chine a
explorer colonisé convertir les natifs
sur toute la côte ouest de l'Amérique du
Sud
bon nombre d'entre eux se plient à la
domination espagnole ceux qui ne
tentèrent pas sont massacrés
on avait mis au point une série de
mesures légales appelées le reikimento
le Reiki voulait que lorsque les
Espagnols arrivaient dans un endroit
pour le conquérir il leur fallait
d'abord lire la Bible sur place si les
paroles de la Bible n'étaient pas
acceptées ils avaient alors le droit
légitime de s'attaquer aux autochtones
puisque ceux-ci refusaient en quelque
sorte d'accepter l'oeuvre du Christ
une stratégie qui fonctionne d'un
village à l'autre dans toute l'Amérique
du Sud
ils se sont aperçus que non seulement ça
leur donnait le loisir de s'emparer de
l'or de ces gens mais qu'il pouvait
aussi exploiter leurs mains d'oeuvre
afin d'extraire davantage d'or et
savez-vous comment il justifiait leur
geste
certains conquistadors prétendaient
simplement qu'on pouvait se le permettre
car on avait affaire à des sauvages
au fur et à mesure que les années
passent leur devient d'autant plus
l'obsession de Pizzaro que ce dernier a
entendu une rumeur selon laquelle un
royaume de l'or se situerait de l'autre
côté de l'impressionnante Cordillère des
Andes
est prêt à consacrer le reste de sa vie
à dénicher ce royaume mais pour mener à
bien son entreprise il lui faut une
ordonnance du nouveau souverain espagnol
Charles V le petit-fils du roi Ferdinand
et de la reine Isabelle en 1528 Pizzaro
retourne en Espagne chercher le soutien
nécessaire à sa campagne au Pérou
le compte-rendu qu'il fait du royaume de
l'or répond en tout point aux
convoitises du roi Charles trois ans
plus tard il repart pour l'Amérique du
Sud armée d'un nouveau mandat pour
s'appeler enfin à la conquête de
l'empire Inca
menée par sa soif d'or pizza reconduit
une troupe de 200 hommes à travers une
expédition éreintante qui dure six mois
au cours de laquelle il détruisent des
villages assassine les indigènes et puis
l'aurore
enfin l'après-midi du 16 novembre 1532
il parvient aux environs de la ville
inca de karamarca
au loin un mirage au lueur chatoyantes
leur apparaît 40000 Incas Paris d'or
temps d'or s'émerveillent en espagnol
que leur armée est aussi flamboyante que
le soleil lui-même
les Incas utilisaient l'or pour
fabriquer des objets de rituels des
objets habituels quotidiens c'était des
vases des bijoux et surtout des coupes
servant aux offrandes à leur dieu qu'on
utilisait pendant les cérémonies
les Incas accueillent le petit bataillon
espagnol alors que pizzaros s'apprête à
être présenté à un homme que les Incas
vénères comme un dieu vivant l'empereur
atawalpa qu'on appelle l'Inca
nos personnes ne se serait avisé de
regarder en face l'Inca c'était une
personne divine il était le fils du
soleil un être complètement au-delà de
toute dimension humaine
lorsque latawal pas a eu connaissance de
l'arrivée de Pizzaro il lui a offert des
présents considérés par les Incas comme
des cadeaux de valeur
Pissarro a pris la viande de canard
séché le linge tissé et les autres
objets qui étaient là et c'est exclamé
c'est de la camelote qu'elle insulte
c'est de l'or que pizza Rover mais ces
soldats sont 200 fois moins nombreux que
l'assemblée qui les entoure les
Espagnols se disent alors que s'il
parviennent à capturer à tawalpa vivant
il se rendront maître de l'empire Inca
tout entier pizza ro décide donc de leur
tendre un piège sous forme de
proposition de réconciliation ces hommes
se postent en embuscade laissant entrer
dans la ville une litière plaqué or sur
laquelle trône l'Inca un homme séduisant
et musclé
âgé d'une trentaine d'années
ils se sont avancés vers atawalpa et le
père barberté s'est approché avec sa
bible pour lui lire le fameux Reiki
raymento
comme il la lui présentait comme
renfermant la Parole de Dieu
atawal passe en est saisi
et la poser contre son oreille pour voir
si le livre allait lui parler
et puisqu'il entendait rien il a jeté la
Bible par terre c'est à ce moment précis
que pizza rod nait l'ordre d'attaquer
la minuscule armée de Pizzaro se mesure
alors à 40000 un cas
[Musique]
des archéologues ont découvert au Pérou
des crânes humains dont les blessures
avaient été colmatées par un plaquage
d'or suggérant qu'il existait déjà une
certaine forme de chirurgie du cerveau
Pizzaro a offert à atawalpa le symbole
le plus sacré du christianisme la Bible
au moment précis où l'Inca jette le
livre saint au sol il en est décidé du
sort de la civilisation inca
les hommes de Pizzaro ouvrent le feu par
une salve de mousquet puis charge avec
leurs épées leur lance les pics flèches
de bois des Incas ne sont pas de taille
à résister aux assaillants
il faut reconnaître qu'à leur arrivée
les Espagnols ont déjà un long passé de
combat tel qu'ils ont pu les mener en
Italie en Suisse et en Hollande
les troupes espagnoles sont bien
entraînés elles ont une solide
expérience ainsi qu'une capacité
militaire supérieure en armes à feu
enfer et en chevaux à celles des Indiens
la vue de ses cavaliers en armure
terrifie les Incas
des weekends au début ils croyait que
c'était des créatures my hommes
mi-cheval que le cavalier son cheval ne
formait qu'un seul être
la victoire est la plus inégale qui soit
en une demi-heure 5000 un cas sont
massacrés les Espagnols eux ne déplorent
pas une seule paire humaine
vizzaro est le seul homme à être blessé
une entaille à la main gauche reçue
alors qu'il protégeait à tawalpa contre
l'un de ses propres soldats enragés
une fois prisonnier l'empereur inca
essaie de négocier sa vie un email il a
conclu un marché avec Pizzaro si ces
sujets parvenaient à porter suffisamment
d'or pour remplir cette pièce on le
libérerait
il a promis de remplir d'or la capacité
d'une pièce entière du plafond jusqu'à
son doigt qui l'a gardé levé pendant ce
temps
précieux de réunir des quatre coins du
Pérou ces objets et ornements somptueux
qu'ils avaient façonnés de magnifiques
pièces d'art qu'ils ont empilés dans
cette pièce jusqu'à ce qu'elle en soit
pleine plus de 5 tonnes d'or remplissent
la pièce largement de quoi faire de
n'importe quelle conquistador un homme
riche
je crois qu'on a fait l'estimation en
valeur actuelle la rançon à massée
devait faire entre 50 et 60 millions de
dollars
atawalpa a tenu parole pizza
l'empereur est maintenu prisonnier
pendant un an après quoi on le juge pour
le seul crime d'être un Incas il est
condamné au bûcher
les Incas croyaient en un retour à la
vie il aurait été très important de
pouvoir conserver le corps des défunts
grâce à sa momification
atawalpa supplie à leur Pizzaro de
choisir une autre façon de l'exécuter
l'alternative de se convertir au
christianisme s'il voulait bénéficier
d'une mort différente
il a accepté
le 29 août 1533 un moine baptise
l'empereur et le nom Dom Fransisco à
tawalpa
au moment précis où il entend prononcer
son nouveau nom l'Inca est assassiné par
strangulation ce qui n'empêche pas
Pizzaro de faire ensuite brûler son
corps les trésors dorés et inestimables
des Incas sont ensuite fondus et le
métal précieux acheminé vers l'Espagne
[Musique]
aucune description des objets Incas qui
ont été fondus tout a été anéanti pour
la postérité
la seule chose qui puisse nous donner
une idée de ce qui a disparu à jamais ce
sont ces quelques pièces qui subsistent
de l'art précolombien et qui sont
conservés dans les musées il s'agit là
d'une perte culturelle tout simplement
inestimable
trois siècles durant les espagnols vont
gouverner le Pérou ils réduisent le
peuple à l'esclavage rase les villages
ce livre au pillage de l'or
mais l'un des plus grands trésors des
Incas leur échappe encore et restera
sauf jusqu'en 1911 la ville sacrée de
Machu Picchu
dissimulés dans un recoin des Andes elle
est pratiquement intacte lorsqu'on la
retrouve
Machu Picchu l'une des merveilles du
monde est une ville taillée à même la
montagne qui s'étale sur 8 km2
[Musique]
. ces lieux saints ne sont qu'une
poignée à avoir survécu à la conquête du
Pérou leur mur résonne encore des
légendes de l'or inca
on raconte aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'histoires sur de l'or qui seraient
cachés dans la montagne
de l'or cachée au fond de lacs où
éparpillés dans plein d'endroits
différents et que les Indiens auraient
dissimulé
les gens qui s'enrichissent dans cette
région des Andes prétendent en général
que c'est parce qu'ils ont découvert
lors que les soldats Incas avaient
réussi à cacher
[Musique]
un pirate mais à sac un empire fondé sur
l'or
lorsque les soldats de Pizzaro arrivent
au Pérou atawalpa et son frère wasquard
sont deux leaders s'opposant dans une
guerre civile atawalpa en sort vainqueur
peu de temps seulement avant que
lui-même ne tombe entre les mains de
Pizzaro
au milieu du 16e siècle l'Espagne riche
de sa conquête des Américains devient le
premier empire sur lequel le soleil ne
se couche jamais
Laure affluait énormément en Espagne
vous voyez la quantité phénoménale d'or
que l'on faisait fondre et comme ce
métal ne provenait pas de mine c'était
par la force des choses des trésors
qu'on faisait fondre mais ça ne leur
suffisait pas il leur fallait encore
réduire les indigènes en esclavage les
asservir au travail des mines afin de
produire toujours plus d'or de l'or
qu'on embarquait ensuite vers l'Europe
pour financer la domination espagnole
dans le monde
est devenu très prospère
c'est une époque au cours de laquelle la
littérature se développe
c'est le début des arbres baroques une
période d'opulence très importante pour
la culture
en 1556 l'empereur Charles V délègue le
trône à son fils Philippe II un
catholique fervent qui consacre sa vie à
éradiquer d'Europe le protestantisme
afin de financer ses projets Philippe va
utiliser l'incroyable man d'or en
provenance des Amériques mais en pleine
mer les navires chargés du précieux
métal demeurent des proies faciles en
particulier pour le terrible l'ennemi de
Philippe l'Angleterre et avec elle le
plus célèbre de ses corsaires Francis
Drake
ils ont des pirates très agressifs ce
sont des pillards même si eux se disent
volontiers explorateurs ce qu'il cherche
essentiellement à partir à la poursuite
des navires espagnols qui transportent
de l'or et de l'argent
ce sont des individus qui ont débuté
comme brigand Drake par exemple dont le
but est d'aborder les bateaux espagnols
croisés sur les océans et de payer leur
cargaison pourvu qu'elles soient
précieuse éventuellement aussi de faire
prisonnier et d'asservir les marins
espagnols à bord de leur navire quand
ils ne les tuaient pas
au cours des années 1570 Drake ainsi au
galion espagnol qui parcourent les mers
ainsi qu'aux intérêts espagnols dans le
nouveau le monde il reprend à Philippe
une partie de sa nouvelle fortune en or
c'est au fait sème la terreur parmi les
marins espagnols et lui valent le surnom
de El drague le dragon
Drake et le corsaire le plus célèbre de
son époque mais aussi un proche ami de
la reine c'est Elisabeth elle-même la
marraine de la plus rentable de ses
traversées initiées en 1577 un parcours
vers l'Ouest qui dure trois ans au cours
duquel il pille effrontément navire et
colonie espagnole
ce voyage est aussi la toute première
traversée autour du monde effectuée par
un anglais
à son retour en 1580 il remet à sa reine
pour plus d'un demi million de livres
sterling en or espagnol
si en Espagne Philippe met a pris la
tête de Drake en Angleterre la reine
Elizabeth le fait chevalier
[Musique]
Philippe est hors de lui depuis
l'Escurial sa retraite située sur un
sommet montagneux il complote sa
vengeance contre Elisabeth et
l'Angleterre
les Curial étant parti un palais en
partie un monastère construit par
Philippe en 1563 il est financé par de
l'or dérobés aux Amériques
Philippe consacre ses vastes richesses à
la gloire de son pays pas la sienne du
lever au coucher c'est un travailleur
acharné qui lit personnellement les
rapports sur ses placements ainsi que
les comptes-rendus qui lui parviennent
de ces mines d'or
pieux jusqu'à l'austérité il s'habille
comme un moine quelconque ces visiteurs
le prennent souvent pour l'un de ces
domestiques
[Musique]
dans les allées et les chapelles de son
Escurial Philippe médite et prie pour
trouver une solution à ces deux grands
problèmes les pirates anglais et les
protestants anglais
à cette époque là toutes les réponses se
rapportaient probablement plus à la
religion qu'à toute autre chose elle
était le moteur idéologique et les
Espagnols en particulier éprouvaient une
véritable passion pour leur catholicisme
la réponse attendue lui parvient sous la
forme d'une guerre sainte financée par
sonore qu'il irait mener directement sur
les terres protestantes ainsi Philippe
commence par ordonner la construction de
la flotte de guerre la plus puissante
que le monde est jamais connu
l'Invincible Armada
les navires de Drake seront cependant
les premiers à attaquer en 1587 contre
la volonté d'Elizabeth celui-ci met le
cap sur le port espagnol de Cadix c'est
là qu'il incendie le chantier naval de
Philippe
l'assaut et dévastateur mais Philippe
fait reconstruire en hâte son armada
l'été 1588 les voiles de la flotte
espagnole de Philippe sont prêtes à être
hissées embarqué à bord de 139 vires 30
000 soldats mettent le cap sur la Manche
ils sont accueillis en personne par le
vieux Némésis de Philippe sœur Francis
Drake promu entre temps vice amiral
canon et météo anglaise vont ensemble
faire payer un très lourd tribu au
navire espagnol
lorsque Philippe apprend la défaite de
son armada il plonge la main simplement
un peu plus profondément dans la case
d'or
confère un sentiment de puissance
après avoir rapporté chez eux cet or les
Espagnols étaient convaincus qu'ils
étaient devenus les maîtres du monde et
qu'il pouvait avoir réponse à tout
pendant 20 ans Philippe continue de
financer sa croisade contre le
protestantisme à l'aide de ses réserves
d'or mais le coût de la domination du
monde s'avère bien supérieure au pouvoir
d'achat de Philippe
[Musique]
ils ont perdu progressivement leur
position de maître des océans ce qui a
fini par couper le flux incessant d'or
et à conduire l'Espagne à son déclin en
tant que grande puissance
lors finit par s'épuiser l'Espagne est
ruiné le roi le plus puissant de la
terre en est réduit à faire placer dans
les rues des troncs pour collecter de
l'argent
il existe un phénomène récurrent dans
l'histoire de l'or c'est l'histoire de
Midas qui avait le don de tout
transformer en or autrement dit en avoir
beaucoup n'est pas forcément synonyme de
bonheur je veux dire qu'on a vite fait
de penser qu'on est devenu puissant
parce qu'on en possède mais en réalité
on y est simplement asservi les nuages
de la guerre finissent par ternir l'âge
d'or de l'Espagne
et au lieu d'être devenu le pays le plus
riche d'Europe ce qui aurait dû se
passer avec toute cette fortune ils ont
fini parmi les plus pauvres ils ont
littéralement claqué leur argent
on emmène Philippe alors âgé de 71 ans
dans cette pièce où il peut contempler
l'hôtel en or qu'il avait dédié à Dieu
il reste 53 jours torturé par ses plaies
paralysés aveugle d'un œil
c'est là qu'il meurt c'est rend dans sa
main une simple croix de bois
[Musique]
en gros le fait que l'or que les
Espagnols avaient rapporté d'Amérique du
Sud était pillée en particulier par la
Grande-Bretagne signifiait que cette
dernière devenait à son tour la plus
grande puissance la plus grande en
termes de position militaire de par le
monde et je dis militaire c'est dans le
sens le plus large y compris sur les
océans qui étaient très vastes
300 ans s'écoulent avant que l'or ne
provoque une nouvelle guerre
une nouvelle guerre déclenchée par un
colonel américain aux cheveux dorés
le pape Sixte 5 promet à Philippe II
d'Espagne un million de du cas en or
soit plus de 30 millions de dollars
actuels si les troupes espagnoles
envahissent l'Angleterre une somme dont
il n'aura en définitive pas besoin de
faire don
par un après-midi torride d'août 1874 un
messager entre au grand galop dans Fort
l'arami Wyoming avec une nouvelle
sensationnelle presque aussitôt le
télégraphe transmet un message de la
frontière américaine à la une de la
presse internationale
on les a enfin découvertes Custer a
trouvé de riches mine d'or et d'argent
dans les collines noires du Dakota au
relief accidenté des géologues viennent
de repérer ce qui figurent alors comme
le filon d'or le plus important de tous
les mysphères ouest sur des terres
appartenant aux Indiens des Plaines
[Musique]
noires sont véritablement le berceau
traditionnel des Indiens des Plaines en
particulier des lacota et des Cheyennes
6 ans auparavant le gouvernement des
États-Unis avait signé un traité avec
les tribus indiennes lui permettant de
les déplacer des riches terre cultivées
des plaines centrales beaucoup avaient
été réinstallé dans les collines noires
une terre considérée par les Indiens des
Plaines comme sacré
va mener une expédition à la Custer
ça faisait vraiment grand pique-nique
seulement un pique-nique d'environ un
millier de soldats une centaine de
chariots couverts un canon l'orchestre
sur des chevaux blancs quelque chose
comme 16 musiciens
ainsi que deux mineurs dont le seul but
est de trouver de l'or alors arrivé dans
les collines noires les soldats se
joignent au mineur afin de participer à
la prospection le 30 juillet 1874 dans
un site surnommé la french Creek ou cric
française un mineur trouve au fond de sa
bataille de minuscules grains jaunes le
surlendemain Custer rédige une dépêche
on a trouvé de l'or en quantité juteuse
j'ai sur ma table 40 ou 50 petites
particules d'or pur chacune d'environ la
taille d'une petite tête d'épingle la
plupart ont été recueillis aujourd'hui
dans une seule et même battée de terre
le télégraphe a immédiatement propagé la
nouvelle et en a rien de temps tout le
monde a appris qu'il y avait de l'or
là-bas
les gens réclamaient à corps et acquis
de pouvoir accéder au collines noires et
bien sûr on a demandé à l'armée de tenir
à distance ces chercheurs d'or l'armée a
donc fait pression sur le gouvernement
pour qu'il trouve une solution en
prétextant qu'elle se retrouvait à
repousser son propre peuple alors
qu'elle était venue chasser les Indiens
le général Philippe cheridan tente de
faire respecter le traité il leur donne
à ses hommes de brûler les chariots
détruire l'outillage et d'arrêter les
chefs souvent les soldats investissaient
le secteur et demandaient à ses mineurs
de plier bagages et de rentrer chez eux
mais ils savaient pertinemment que les
mineurs attendaient en retour qu'ils
aient quitté le site pour reprendre leur
travail
un chercheur d'or du nom de John Maxwell
se plaint
l'unique raison pour laquelle ces
collines ne sont pas encore occupées
c'est qu'on s'attache à satisfaire les
caprices de quelques sauvages misérables
qui réclament que cette magnifique
région reste une exploitée
à la différence des Incas d'Amérique du
Sud les tribus des plaines d'Amérique du
Nord ne voient aucun intérêt à utiliser
le métal jaune
c'est cependant leur or
eilles le bison jouait un rôle essentiel
chez les Indiens des Plaines
toutes leurs cultures tournaient autour
de l'animal qui leur fournissaient la
totalité de ce dont ils avaient besoin
leur tente leurs vêtements leur
nourriture leur religion les militaires
savaient bien ça et ils se sont dit que
s'il tuait les bisons on éliminait par
la même occasion les Indiens l'armée a
donc distribué des munitions gratuites
au chasseurs de bisons et les encourager
à battre l'animal
et malheureusement le bison devient une
autre victime de la soif d'or de l'homme
blanc
[Musique]
en 1875 les collines noires sont
envahies de mineurs le gouvernement
américain abandonne sa mise en
application du traité et décide plutôt
d'acheter la terre aux Indiens ces
derniers refusent
même les Indiens entretenant de bonnes
relations avec le gouvernement savait
qu'il ne pouvait pas vendre les collines
noires en 1875 un fort pourcentage des
Indiens d'Amérique a déjà été concentré
dans des réserves quelques-uns résistent
encore comme Crazy Horse Sitting Bull
ils ne prennent pas un malin plaisir à
semer le trouble en tirant sur les
blancs
ils essaient simplement de faire
respecter leurs tradition en même temps
ils sont loin d'être prêt à signer
quelques traités que ce soit
ainsi au printemps 1876 l'armée
américaine reçoit l'ordre de traquer et
d'arrêter les chefs Crazy Horse et
Sitting Bull puis de les escorter vers
une réserve loin des riches terrains
aurifères l'ordre émane du même homme
qui a découvert de l'or dans les
collines noires le lieutenant-colonel
George custas
j'ai de quoi battre à plat de couture
tous les Indiens de ce continent grâce à
ma 7e cavalerie
le 25 juin 1876 les éclaireurs de Custer
repèrent un village indien sur les rives
de la rivière little big
horniens dans ce camp au bord de la
Little Big Horn
le troupeau de chevaux seul était estimé
à 25000 têtes
Custer les a pris complètement par
surprise
mais la situation s'est retournée
aussitôt contre lui parce que les
Indiens au lieu de s'enfuir comme le
faisait en été les Indiens des Plaines
ont cette fois contre attaqué
30 minutes suffisent anéantir les
troupes de Custer la bataille de Little
Big Horn représente la plus importante
victoire des Indiens de l'histoire de
l'Ouest mais c'est une victoire de
courte durée l'armée voulait sa revanche
dans l'année qui a suivi pas un seul
indien impliqué dans cette bataille n'a
échappé soit à la mort soit à sa
concentration dans une réserve
dans les collines noires place nette a
été faite pour l'homme blanc en quête
d'or
il ne pouvait pas comprendre la passion
des blancs pour ce minéral il aura fallu
beaucoup de temps pour commencer à
réaliser qu'il y avait de l'argent en
jeu avec ses collines
les Indiens des collines noires étaient
coupables de vivre dessus de l'un des
plus rigidement d'or d'Amérique du Nord
ce qui était terres sacré devient le
chantier de la home stake mean
la plus riche mine d'or de l'histoire
américaine
si le gouvernement des États-Unis a
offert aux tribus de les dédommager pour
leur collines noires celle-ci ont
toujours refusé pour les descendants des
Indiens des Plaines il s'agit toujours
de leur terre sacrée dont aucune somme
d'or des Blancs ne pourra jamais
compenser la perte
[Musique]
l'Angleterre part en guerre pour sa
reine et pour l'or
[Musique]
un dixième de tout l'or trouvé aux
États-Unis provient de la home stake
mean dans les collines noires du Dakota
du Sud
en 1886 la découverte d'or sur ce site
d'Afrique du Sud métamorphose
pratiquement du jour au lendemain se
trou perdu colonial la néerlandais en
nation la plus riche et la plus
puissante d'Afrique
il faut replacer dans leur contexte ses
découvertes en Afrique du Sud
parce que par la suite près de la moitié
de tout l'or jamais produit dans le
monde le sera précisément dans ce pays
tout à coup une région qu'on connaissait
pour ses plumes d'autruche et pour ses
tribus bizarres qui secouraient après
pour s'entretuer cette région devient le
terrain de jeu d'aventuriers a couru du
monde entier en quête de richesse
à la découverte d'or c'est une paix
difficile qui s'instaure en Afrique du
Sud
5 ans auparavant les bords parlant le
Néerlandais ont réussi à sauver leur
indépendance des Anglais
[Musique]
la région se divise désormais entre ces
bords des républiques d'Afrique du Sud
et les Britanniques qui forment la
colonie du Cap
les Hollandais dominaient et géré
quelque chose comme la moitié du pays
l'autre partie restait sous autorité
anglaise
mais dès l'instant où l'on découvre de
l'or en territoire bord un afflux de
britannique menace de submerger la
petite république
ils étaient assis sur une sorte de vaste
eldorado
et tout d'un coup ils se sont retrouvés
envahis par des milliers de chasseurs de
trésors
le nouveau cheval de bataille de la
Grande-Bretagne consiste donc à protéger
ses concitoyens ainsi que leur mine d'or
rattaché à la Hollande les premiers
investisseurs dans les mines d'or
étaient essentiellement des Anglais
Kruger les taxés alors que ceux-ci
n'avait aucun pouvoir politique
les 9 années qui suivent voient
s'exacerber les tensions entre les bords
et les voisins britanniques
en 1895 Cécile rods alors Premier
ministre de la colonie britannique du
Cap décide de passer à l'action
Road lui-même personnellement à la tête
d'immense mine de diamants en voici 100
mercenaires pour tenter de renverser
Kruger et son gouvernement beau mais ils
vont endurer une cuisson de défaite
[Musique]
en septembre 1899 la Grande-Bretagne
envoie en Afrique du Sud un corps
expéditionnaire de 10000 hommes sous le
prétexte de protéger si mineur et leur
or
[Musique]
le 12 octobre le président Kruger
ordonne de mener une grève préventive
mille soldats assiègent les colonies
britanniques de Kimberley et de MAF King
et chassent les citoyens britanniques
vers des abris de fortune
parmi les personnes capables de
subsister avec le peu de nourriture dont
ils disposent 7 mois durant figurent
Sarah Wilson l'attente de Winston
Churchill elle garde tout son flagme
dans ses lettres adressée vers
l'Angleterre
le petit déjeuner de ce matin de la
saucisse de cheval le déjeuner du hachis
et de la viande de mule et des sauts et
le curry impeccables
son optimisme est justifiée on envoie
bientôt davantage de soldats
britanniques en Afrique du Sud qui
parviennent à lever le siège des villes
anglaises
9 mois après le début des hostilités la
victoire s'annonce
en mai 1946 000 soldats britanniques
sous les ordres du maraîchal lors de
Frédéric Roberts ainsi que Lord et
ratios kischner convergent vers la
capitale bord de Johannesburg
ils arrivent tout près de l'objet de
leur convoitise les terrains aurifères
[Musique]
au développement futur de l'Empire
britannique
économiquement comme industriellement
c'est pour ça que les Anglais étaient
prêts à déployer autant de moyens pour
être sûr de leur victoire
encerclé par une force britannique
écrasante Kruger fait alors une
proposition à l'ordre bertz si les
Anglais les laissent partir sain et sauf
les bords acceptent en retour de leur
abandonnée Johannesburg et le contrôle
des mines Roberts accepte le marché de
peur que les bords ne se mettent à
saboter les mines
Robert s'est déclaré il y a fort à
craindre que les mines et leurs machines
soient endommagées
vous imaginez son raisonnement
parce que Robert comme tous les autres
savaient pertinemment que quand bien
même il faudrait reconstruire derrière
lors demeurerait la chose essentielle
le 30 mai
1912000 soldats morts armés jusqu'aux
dents quitte à cheval Johannesburg et
monte vers les collines environnantes
le lendemain les Britanniques entrent
dans la ville dont ils prennent
possession ainsi que des mines d'or le
maréchal Roberts annonce la fin du
conflit
les derniers mots célèbres il a envoyé
un message à la tension des observateurs
militaires de différents pays qui se
trouvaient sur place les Américains les
Allemands les Japonais ou bien les
Français il leur a dit messieurs merci
pour votre aide nous sommes en juin 1900
merci pour votre assistance vos
observations ça a été un réel plaisir
que de vous divertir tout ce qu'il nous
reste à faire dorénavant c'est de
nettoyer le terrain vous pouvez donc
tous repartir chez vous mais en réalité
les bords ne sont pas prêts à capituler
si les Anglais ont l'or eux possèdent
non seulement un armement parmi les plus
sophistiqués mais aussi la mobilité
c'était les meilleurs cavaliers qui
soient depuis l'époque d'Attila Alain ou
de la Horde dorée des jeunes qui avaient
littéralement grandi sur une selle
forte de tous les hommes valident entre
16 et 60 ans l'armée bord commence par
mener une guérilla
des commandos frappent don de Séoul
disparaissant aussi furtivement qu'ils
sont apparus
si vous préférez les bords faisaient
presque figure d'ennemis invisibles il
ne portait pas d'uniforme on ne pouvait
pas les repérer
il ne repartait pas en troupes il menait
leur combat puis se disperser aussitôt
vers leur ferme
c'est probablement la première fois
qu'on utilisait dans une guerre une
tactique de guérilla cette façon de
procéder parait d'éclair sur les Anglais
est aussi ce qui a fait éterniser cette
guerre
pendant deux ans les bords harcèlent les
Britanniques qui investissent encore
plus d'hommes et d'argent dans le
conflit en 1901 près d'un demi million
de soldats britanniques sont postés en
Afrique du Sud soit 10 fois plus que
l'armée bord malgré ces mesures la
guerre traîne en longueur et les
Britanniques demeurent incapables de
reprendre la main dans un élan de
désespoir il décide de changer de
méthode il brûle les fermes détruisent
les récoltes abattent le bétail le
résultat est dramatique
[Musique]
plus de 100.000 femmes et enfants bord
sont rassemblés dans des camps connus
sous le nom de camp de concentration
c'est la toute première fois qu'on
utilise ce terme
les Britanniques avaient décidé de se
distinguer par de nouvelles façons de
mener une guerre qui mettait tout à coup
en cause la population civile on
considère en général cette période comme
celle de l'invention des camps de
concentration
on y enfermait les civils pour qu'il ne
puisse pas aider les gens
les statistiques qui prêtent le plus à
réfléchir sur cette guerre nous viennent
de l'intérieur même de ces camps de
concentration 22
000 enfants âgés de moins de 16 ans ils
mourront de faim et de maladies soit
plus que le nombre de soldats tombés
dans les deux camps
le 31 mai 1902 enfin après quasiment
trois ans de combat désespérés les bords
sont poussés à se rendre par la famille
la victoire des Britanniques a assuré à
l'Empire un flux continu et conséquent
d'or et cela jusqu'à ce que l'Afrique du
Sud finisse par obtenir son indépendance
en 1948
mais la production d'or revient cher
[Musique]
il était évident que les découvertes
faites en Afrique du Sud s'annonçaient
comme énorme quelles allaient devenir la
force dominante dans l'industrie minière
de l'or pour les dizaines d'années à
venir et que l'on n'en voyait pas le
bout de ses mines certaines ont été
exploitées pendant plus d'un siècle
c'était une source pour laquelle le
gouvernement britannique était convaincu
que ça valait la peine de se battre
aujourd'hui les mines du 8 waters round
produisent annuellement pour près de 4
milliards de dollars en or
[Musique]